meanwhile in Italy authorities said on
Sunday that a further 651 people had
died from the corona virus that's fewer
than Saturday's record number of deaths
but it's still the second worst day so
far
italy has closed non-essential
businesses to try to control the
outbreak and outside help is on the way
doctors from cuba and medical supplies
from Russia have been dispatched to help
support the overwhelmed medical system
an eerie sight that's now the norm in
many Italian cities Rome's Piazza
Venezia deserted apart from police cars
and military vehicles rules confining
Italians to their homes were tightened
even further the Prime Minister
announced all public officers building
sites and businesses would close unless
they're essential to keeping the
country's supply chain going those
sacrifices that today can look like a
step backwards will allow us tomorrow's
to come back soon into our factories
into our offices into our squares into
the arms of relatives and friends we are
giving up our beloved habits because we
love Italy but we won't give up our
confidence in the future united we will
make it as Italy ramped up its lockdown
measures with a greater police and
military presence help also arrived from
another country doctors and nurses from
Cuba touched down in Milan on Sunday
they're there to provide support and
expertise to the hospitals in Italy
which are increasingly overwhelmed by
the number of patients those doctors
have fought Ebola in West Africa have
been to natural disaster areas where
there's been earthquakes floods and we
come to bring our solidarity for the
human commitment that we keep with our
profession and with our country and the
world behind the closed doors and
shuttered windows of the Lombardi region
people are already reeling from the
ever-increasing death toll here like all
over the country just one hope that
maybe Italy will emerge soon from one of
the darkest chapters in recent history
well unless you Alessio Perona is
covering this story and joins us now
from Milan the capital of Lombardi in
Italy unless you what's the latest
what's the situation at the moment in
Lombardi all right good morning and
thanks for having me I think the
situation is there's a lot of death and
trauma lately especially in the
provinces of Bergamo Brescia Cremona to
the east of Milan to the east of here
spoke to a priest recently near Bergamo
and so many people had died in the
community where he served in embro that
he told me it's gonna be difficult to
even imagine what life would be like
when this is over because so many iconic
people of the village are gone and so
we've all seen the pictures we've all
seen the pictures of the trucks carrying
bodies away from Bergamo we've seen the
pictures of the rows of caskets waiting
to be buried in the city's Cemetery and
I think at this point all of lung body's
wondering when does this stop when will
it slow down when do we see the offense
or the lockdown that's been in place for
over two weeks already we were told in
the beginning that we would see the
effects in two or three weeks time so
we're about to enter the third week of
the of our lockdown here in Lombardy and
so people are just collectively I think
nervously waiting to see that the spread
slow down finally looking at Italy as a
whole we did see a slight drop in the
number the daily number of deaths
reported for the country as a whole are
things still getting worse in Italy or
are there indications that the outbreak
may have peaked yes you you're right
even here in Lombardy yesterday I mean
it's it's still hard to call the data
positive or a good sign when so many
people are dying but compared to
Saturday's information
yesterday's bulletin was actually it
looked it looked much better so I'm
looking at the figures now and in
Lombardi we
almost 550 dead people on Saturday and
and 361 yesterday so it's 200 feet less
so now the authorities have warned us
it's it's hard it's hard to tell now if
this is a sign that their spread is
slowing or if we're just what if it's
just one day would give day good data
unless here thank you very much for
talking to us that was journalists
Alessio padronia
in Milan thanks for having me